so we've had extraordinary rains here
all around sydney i'm in the northwest
of the city but even maneuvering around
here has become very difficult it's
flooded fields and houses businesses
cars underwater you can see one of the
major bridges just outside of sydney
behind me our cameraman is going to show
you how far that flood water extends at
least a mile it's broken its banks it
submerged the bridge
and people in this area when you speak
to them they say that they're expecting
things to get much worse before they get
better and that's because these rivers
the the flood levels are still
increasing they're expected to peak
overnight we've seen the emergency crews
out and about some 30 000 people have
been told to either evacuate from their
homes or to get their flood plans ready
so that when the crews say it's time to
get out they're ready to do it we've
also seen them out on boats already
having to get some people
some families out of their houses when
the waters have risen too quickly
the amazing thing here though is this
has been going on for months and months
this isn't a one-off flood some of these
areas have had three or four floods
just this year so they're exhausted
they're tired they say they clean up
from one flood and then suddenly another
flood
arrives remembering also at the
beginning of the year we had that
massive flood event up on the north
coast of new south wales in lismore 10
000 people in that area are still
homeless
so everyone here is frustrated that the
flooding is still continuing they say
that the state government and the
federal government needs to come up with
a plan to protect them but they're
living in low-lying flood-prone areas
and right now australia is in the middle
of a la nina weather event so that means
that the entire east coast of australia
is being constantly hammered by these
extreme
weather events now climate scientists
are saying that this could continue for
another couple of months over the winter
and into the spring so people are
bracing for even more flood events
two years of la nina so far and now
they're saying that this could extend
into a third year so a really pretty
dramatic scene that we have here not
only on the outskirts of sydney but
stretching along the coast
and as i said emergency crews and
officials are warning people to stay at
home to cancel their school holidays and
just wait for these flood waters to drop